تاره يوجه انتقادا لاذعا واخرى يوبخ اداره
العمليه العسكريه الروسيه في اوكرانيا
هكذا اصبحت خطابته في الاونه الاخيره لون
وعتاب واتهامات بحجب الذخيره عنهم مع تكبد
قوته خسائر فادحه في الارواح
فبعد شهور طوال لم يهدا عزيز الرصاص
والمدافع في باخموت تلك المعركه الداميه
التي استنزفت الجيشين على حد سواء الروسيه
والاوكراني لكن قائد مجموعه فاجنر الروسيه
لم يطق صبرا وعلى ما يبدو فانه على شفا
خيانه عظمى للرئيس فلاديمير بوتين بحسب
صحيفه واشنطن بوست الامريكيه التي ذكرت
انها اطلعت على وثائق استخباراتيه تقول ان
بروجين قدم عرضا استثنائيا لاوكرانيا مطلع
يناير الماضي ونقل اقتراحه لمديريه
الاستخبارات الاوكرانيه عبر اتصالات سريه
محاولا اقناع قوه كييف بالانسحاب من
باخموت مقابل الكشف عن مواقع القوات
الروسيه خارج محيط المدينه اي ان بريكوجين
يتنازل عن انتصار صغير في مناطق اخرى
مقابل السيطره على باخموت ام معارك
اوكرانيا واطولها
بدورها ووفق تسريبات منصه ديسكورد رفضت
المخابرات الاوكرانيه العرض عرض قد لا
يشرح فحسب مدى تازم وضع فاغنر في باخموت
وانما حجم خلاف بريكوجين مع القاده الروس
بمن فيهم وزير الدفاع
خاصه وان الايام الماضيه شهدت عداء علنيا
بينهم بحسب الصحيفه